Salut !
Vous n'êtes pas très étonnés
que je sois fasciné
par les cerveaux
un petit peu légendaires.
Alors que ce soit clair,
les grands esprits,
ils n'ont pas forcément un cerveau
plus gros ou qui brille dans la nuit.
Mais ça n'a pas empêché
que quelqu'un vole celui d'Einstein,
qu'un homme ait vécu
pendant 30 ans sans cerveau.
Ou qu'un autre homme
ait assuré son cerveau
pour la bagatelle
de 1,5 million d'euros.
Pourquoi ?
Et bien, c'est exactement ce qu'on va
décortiquer dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui.
En parlant de gros cerveau,
Loïc, générique.
Albert Einstein est vraiment devenu
le symbole de l'intelligence humaine.
Si vous connaissez pas son travail,
vous connaissez au moins
son visage légendaire.
Ou cette photo là.
Et surtout son équation qui est
probablement la plus connue au monde,
pas forcément la plus comprise,
mais la plus connue, c'est sûr.
Einstein et né le 14 mars 1879,
il était physicien théoricien.
Et c'est lui qui a expliqué en 1905,
la théorie de la relativité restreinte.
Théorie connue
sous l'équation E = MC²,
qui a en gros une formule d'équivalence
entre la masse et l'énergie.
Il a aussi largement
contribué au développement
de la mécanique quantique
et à la cosmologie.
Et bien sûr, il reçoit en 1921,
le prix Nobel de physique pour
son travail sur l'effet photoélectrique.
Le 18 avril 1955, Einstein décède.
Il a 76 ans, il est à l'hôpital de Princeton
dans le New-Jersey aux Etats-Unis.
Et son corps entier est incinéré,
conformément, en fait,
aux dernières volontés qu'il avait
laissées dans son testament.
Tout son corps, non !
Son cerveau résiste
encore et toujours au feu.
Et se fait la malle
sur ses petits pieds,
rentre à la maison,
se fait un chocolat chaud,
en se matant
Les Marseillais à Cancún.
C'est faux.
Mais c'est parce que
l'émission n'existait pas à l'époque.
- Ah c'est pour ça,
sinon c'est ce qu'il aurait fait.
- Sinon vraiment, il aurait fait ça.
- Okay.
- En vrai, qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Le médecin de garde
de l'hôpital de Princeton...
Princeton, Princeton.
- Princeton !
- Ah bah oui, Princeton.
Non, Princeton.
Il s'appelle Thomas Stoltz Harvey,
il a alors 42 ans.
Et il fait son rapport d'autopsie.
Le décès est dû à une rupture
d'anévrisme de l'aorte abdominale.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là,
aurait dû s'arrêter là
et rester banale, normale.
Mais Thomas ne fait pas vraiment
ce qu'on lui demande, il se dit :
"C'est dommage de laisser passer
et partir ce bel organe là, au feu là.
Hein, quand même.
Un beau cerveau comme ça".
Et puis coup de bol,
il a une scie chirurgicale.
Et comme lui le dimanche,
il fait partie du club
les amoureux de la scie à bois.
Et bien il se dit :
"Ah bah tiens, je vais découper
la boîte crânienne d'Albert.
Je prends le cerveau d'Albert.
Et puis sans aucune autorisation,
je vais le mettre dans la valise
et l'emporter à la maison avec moi".
On aurait tous fait ça.
T'aurais fait ça Loïc ?
- Absolument pas.
- Moi non plus.
- Le reste du corps,
ça part à l'incinération.
Et...
Et ah non, on me dit que non.
On me dit que le reste du corps
ne part pas à l'incinération.
Parce qu'en fait, l'ophtalmo aussi,
est passé pour récupérer...
Je vous jure, c'est vrai.
Pour récupérer les yeux d'Einstein.
parce que vraiment,
tout le monde se sert.
Il y a un petit côté open-bar.
Donc une fois que c'était bon,
que tout le monde a pris
ce qu'il voulait.
Bon ça c'est bien.
Et bien le corps d'Einstein
part à l'incinération
et ses cendres seront dispersées
dans un endroit resté secret,
comme il l'avait demandé.
Au moins, il y a un truc
qu'il a demandé, qui a été respecté.
On a incinéré un pied.
On a incinéré un orteil,
parce que vraiment
tout le monde avait pris un truc.
Le fait est que Thomas Harvey
ramène le cerveau à la maison.
Et ça c'est pas une phrase
qu'on dit souvent quand même.
Thomas une fois chez lui,
pèse le cerveau.
Première surprise, celui-ci
ne pèse que 1230 grammes,
contre 1350 grammes
en moyenne chez un homme.
Harvey fait des dizaines de mesures,
il immortalise le cerveau en prenant
des dizaines de clichés
sous toutes les coutures.
Puis Harvey se dit :
"Je vais me la jouer Dexter.
La série existe pas encore,
mais je vais faire pareil".
Il prend son petit scalpel et découpe
les hémisphères cérébraux
en 240 blocs de 10 centimètres cube.
Des centaines de lames.
On appelle ça des lames qu'on met
sous les lamelles pour le microscope.
Bref, il fait un petit travail d'orfèvre
pour tenter de percer
les secrets du cerveau d'Einstein
et donc du génie humain.
Sauf que Thomas est pathologiste.
Il sait dire pourquoi quelqu'un est mort,
mais il n'a pas vraiment les compétences
pour analyser en détail
l'organe d'Albert.
Dire si les neurones du monsieur,
étaient particulièrement
performants ou non
dans telle ou telle ère du cerveau,
ça il sait pas faire.
Jusqu'en 1978, personne
n'entend parler de son travail.
Jusqu'à ce que Steven Levy,
journaliste dans le New-Jersey
le retrouve, thomas,
dans le Kansas.
Levy arrive, cogne chez lui,
il commence à discuter avec lui.
Et il raconte qu'au bout d'un moment,
Harvey a admis qu'il avait
emporté un petit truc avec lui.
C'est-à-dire qu'il avait pris
le cerveau d'Einstein,
et qu'il était encore
en sa possession.
Harvey marche alors
vers une caisse marquée "Cidre Costa".
Et en sort deux bocaux dans lesquelles
flottent les restes du cerveau d'Einstein.
Suite à l'article de Levy, Harvey
enchaîne énormément d'interviews.
Mais c'est qu'en 1982 qu'il acceptera
de partager son précieux.
Il envoie alors un morceau
du cerveau à Marian Diamond,
neuroanatomiste en Californie.
Et en 1985, 30 ans après
la mort du célèbre scientifique.
Un premier article sort
dans la revue Neurology
à propos du cerveau d'Albert Einstein.
A partir de ce moment là,
ce sont pas moins de 18 chercheurs
qui vont avoir la joie, le plaisir
de recevoir chacun
un petit échantillon de la bestiole.
Que ce soit sous forme de morceaux,
de lames histologiques,
ou simplement de photos.
Le tout envoyé par Harvey lui-même,
il est sympa,  il partage.
Aujourd'hui, donc une demi douzaine
d'études plus tard.
Le mystère du cerveau
d'Albert Einstein reste entier.
Chacun des rapports attribuant
l'intelligence du physicien
à une caractéristique
anatomique différente.
Pour l'anecdote,
Thomas Harvey est même allé
jusqu'à filer un bout
du cerveau à un Japonais,
qui collectionnait tout ce qui avait
un rapport avec Einstein.
En 1993, il s'appelle Kenji,
il vient sonner chez le médecin,
chez Harvey, Thomas Harvey.
Il lui demande s'il peut avoir un petit
bout du cerveau de son idole et tout.
Harvey réfléchit et dit :
"Bah ouais, bien sûr".
Il offre un bocal.
Il ouvre un bocal plutôt,
il sort un morceau sur
la planche à pain avec une hachette.
Il fait : "Tiens c'est pour toi".
Il l'a mis dans un pot avec un peu
de formol quand même, c'est sympa.
Si ça vous intéresse,
il y a un documentaire
qui a suivi Kenji dans sa quête
de tout ce qui avait
un rapport avec Einstein.
On le voit voir le cerveau d'Einstein
pour la première fois,
on le voit faire la demande
du petit bout, etc.
Selon les rumeurs, Harvey avait
des tonnes de demandes étranges.
Michael Jackson lui-même,
avait aussi voulu obtenir le cerveau,
il avait proposé 3 millions de dollars pour
l'ajouter à sa collection d'œuvres d'art.
Ce que Thomas Harvey avait refusé,
fidèle à sa promesse faite
à Hans Albert, le fils d'Einstein,
qui avait finit quand même
par lui donner l'autorisation,
à posteriori, de garder
le cerveau de son père.
Donc Thomas a toujours refusé
l'argent qu'on lui a proposé.
Et à la mort de Thomas Harvey,
en 2007, sa famille a légué
les restes du cerveau
au musée national de la santé
et de la médecine de Chicago.
Le musée obtient alors
des fonds privés
pour numériser
cette collection en 2012.
Et donc le cerveau d'Albert Einstein
devient une attraction
pour les scientifiques
et tous les passionnés.
Une application payante
a été créée et permet d'observer
toutes les lames au microscope,
qu'avait préparé Harvey.
J'ai pas réussi
à trouver cette appli
et je sais pas vraiment
si elle existe encore.
Mais elle a existée
un moment donné, ça c'est sûr.
En 1999, Martin.
Alors je l'appelle Martin,
c'est un prénom inventé.
C'est quelqu'un qui a vraiment existé,
c'est un français de 44 ans.
Donc Martin mène une vie
parfaitement normale.
Il est marié, il a des enfants,
il est fonctionnaire dans l'administration.
Tout va bien !
Et un jour, il a une petite douleur
qui apparaît dans la jambe.
Il se dit, je vais aller
à l'hôpital voir ce qu'il y a.
Donc il va à l'hôpital
Timone de Marseille.
Parce qu'il a peur
d'avoir une sciatique.
Il arrive, un médecin le prend
en charge, discute avec lui.
Et il a découvert qu'il prend
des médicaments contre l'anxiété,
depuis qu'il est tout petit.
Le médecin creuse un peu plus loin.
Et découvre que la prescription de
ce médicament date de son enfance
et est liée à une hydrocéphalie.
En gros, ça veut dire que
le cerveau de Martin présentait
un trop plein de liquide
encéphalo rachidien.
C'est le liquide dans lequel baigne
notre cerveau et notre moelle épinière.
En gros, c'est un peu l'air bag
qu'il y a dans la tête,
ce qui fait que quand on secoue
comme ça le cerveau.
Et bien...
J'ai secoué trop fort,
je te jure c'est vrai.
Mais en gros, le cerveau
se cogne pas contre le crâne,
parce que sinon ça irait
pas très bien pour nous.
Donc c'est ce liquide qu'il y a autour.
Et bien ce liquide s'il est présent
en trop grande quantité,
il peut amener les tissus cérébraux
à se comprimer.
C'est jamais bon.
Et en règle général,
les médecins soignent ça
en évacuant le liquide
vers une autre partie du corps.
Et dans le cas de Martin,
il y a un tuyau qui avait été installé.
Il partait de son cerveau
vers une membrane
qui était située sous son abdomen,
où le liquide était évacué
ensuite naturellement par le corps.
Tu vois par où.
Le petit Martin, il grandit.
Et à l'âge de 14 ans,
le tuyau se fait un petit peu court.
En plus, Martin présente des signes
de problèmes de coordination,
et une diminution de la force
musculaire à la jambe gauche.
Autant d'indicateurs
qui poussent à croire
qu'il est vraiment temps
de changer le tuyau.
C'est d'ailleurs ce que font
les médecins de l'époque.
Fin de l'histoire de Martin.
Terminé.
On passe à quand il a 44 ans.
Le docteur de l'hôpital de la Timone
décide de lui faire passer un scanner
pour vérifier que tout se passe bien
dans sa boîte crânienne.
Et que le liquide continue,
à bien être évacué
correctement vers son abdomen.
Au bout de trente ans,
c'est pas mal d'être prudent
et de faire une petite
vérification de routine.
Et là je vous jure,
j'aimerais voir la tête
du technicien qui a fait le scanner.
Pourquoi ?
Pour ça :
La boîte crânienne
de Martin est quasiment vide.
Ou alors elle est pas vraiment vide,
elle est remplie à 90%
de liquide Encéphalo rachidien.
Avec le passé de Martin,
le neurologue a vite eu la conclusion
que le petit tuyau s'était bouché.
Et donc que le liquide s'est accumulé.
Il a dû se boucher à l'époque
où on lui a changé le tuyau.
Et donc ça fait 30 ans
que c'est accumulé.
Et la place occupée par le liquide,
c'est celle qu'aurait dû prendre le cerveau.
Cerveau qui a été contraint
de se développer le long des parois,
sous la forme d'une bande de seulement
quelques centimètres d'épaisseur.
C'est-à-dire que c'est l'inverse en fait.
Il a quelques centimètres
d'épaisseur tout le long du crâne.
Et tout l'intérieur,
c'est le liquide Encéphalo rachidien.
Et le plus fou,
c'est que malgré ça,
Martin a une vie normale,
avec une femme, des enfants.
Il n'a pas d'handicap notable,
toutes les parties
de son cerveau sont bien présentes.
Mais elles ont toutes été aplaties,
pour rejoindre la périphérie
de la boîte crânienne.
Même le corps calleux,
qui est l'endroit où les connexions
se font entre les deux hémisphères
a été repoussé vers le haut du crâne.
S'il avait été sectionné,
les gestes de Martin auraient pas
pu être coordonnés par exemple.
La seule différence
notable chez Martin,
c'est que sur les tests
d'intelligence classiques,
ses résultats étaient assez faibles.
Son QI atteint difficilement les 70.
C'est un peu faible.
Parce que quand même,
ça montre les limites
de la plasticité du cerveau
qui ne peut pas
être réduit indéfiniment,
sans que les capacités
des neurones ou cognitives
en fassent un petit peu les frais.
Mais en vrai, c'est quand même fou.
Parce que le cerveau
est élastique, certes.
Mais les contorsions
qu'ont dû subir les connexions
des neurones les plus éloignés
du cerveau de Martin,
doivent être complètement folles.
Il a peut-être 70 de QI, Martin.
Mais la structure de son cerveau
et la manière dont il s'est adapté,
c'est complètement hallucinant.
Cette histoire nous montre
à quel point le cerveau humain
peut s'adapter et se développer aussi,
face à des contraintes extrêmes.
A condition que celles-ci
interviennent sur le long terme.
Petit à petit et de manière
quasi imperceptible.
Si c'est un choc violent,
évidemment, c'est plus compliqué.
Dominic O'brien possède lui,
un cerveau qui remplit bien
toute sa boîte crânienne.
ça, il n'y a pas de souci.
A tel point qu'elle pourrait
peut-être même
être un peu trop petite
pour ce qui lui fait ingurgiter.
Il est mnémoniste.
Vous commencez à connaître
ce terme, je pense, sur ma chaîne.
En gros, il s'agit
d'une personne qui est capable
de mémoriser une liste
de choses inhabituelles,
particulièrement longue.
Dominic est né le 10 août 1957.
Et en 1987, il avait 30 ans.
Il regarde sur la BBC,
l'émission "Record breakers".
C'était bien dit là !
- Celui là, c'était bien dit.
- Eh merci.
Dans cette émission, on montre
des personnes qui battent des records,
de n'importe quel domaine.
Et il découvre alors Carvelo.
C'est un mnémoniste
Britannique qui mémorise
un paquet de 52 cartes à jouer,
en moins de trois minutes.
Alors elles sont pas dans l'ordre,
elles ont été mélangées
juste avant Loïc.
Ne fait pas cette tête.
A ce moment précis,
O'brien se découvre une passion
et va jusqu'à développer son propre
système de mémorisation :
Le système Dominic.
Il s'agit ni plus, ni moins,
d'une version de la table de rappel
devenue un PAO.
J'ai fait une vidéo sur les PAO.
En gros, c'est personnage-action-objet.
Pour faire très simple,
il associe chaque carte à jouer
à un personnage célèbre,
à une action et un objet.
Et pour mémoriser,
il prend trois cartes dans les mains.
La première carte à jouer,
il prend le personnage.
Il l'associe à l'action
de la deuxième carte
et à l'objet de la troisième carte.
Et comme ça,
il se souvient de petites scénettes
trois cartes par trois cartes.
C'est très cool,
et c'est finalement très proche
de ma table de rappel personnelle.
Je vous conseille d'ailleurs
de vous en créer une,
c'est très pratique pour
vous souvenir d'un nombre long,
en très peu de temps.
Si vous avez rien
sous la main pour le noter.
Dominic est également capable
de retenir 100 portraits photos
en 30 minutes, et d'associer
les noms qui correspondent.
Ou de réciter un poème
d'une cinquantaine de lignes
alors qu'il l'aura lu qu'une seule fois.
Sans erreur, au mot près.
Dominic, il fait quoi ?
Il fait son petit bonhomme de chemin
et grâce à ses techniques,
il devient le champion du monde
de mémoire, huit fois d'affilée.
Et on lui décerne le titre
de cerveau de l'année en 1994.
En 2002, il rentre dans le livre
le Guinness des records,
après avoir eu une séquence
aléatoire de 2808 cartes à jouer.
Soit l'équivalent de 54 paquets
entiers de 52 cartes.
Il l'a fait en ne faisant
que huit erreurs,
dont quatre qu'il a
instantanément corrigées.
Genre il a dit :
"Huit de carreau, non c'est pas ça,
c'est deux de trèfle".
Bref, Dominic crée
ses techniques de mémorisation,
il écrit des livres, il anime
des conférences sur le sujet,
il passe sur les chaînes télé
de tous les pays,
il accumule des récompenses,
liées à son travail réalisé
à l'aide de son cerveau.
Cerveau qu'il finira par assurer pour la
modique somme de 1,5 million d'euros,
ce qui reste tout de même
très bon marché.
Si on rapporte ce tarif
au prix du neurone, pas si cher.
68 à 100 milliards de neurones,
du coup ça va.
Eh je t'en prends 10.
Voilà pour l'histoire
de ces trois grands cerveaux.
N'oubliez pas de liker cette vidéo,
si elle vous a plu.
Je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
vous pouvez vous abonner.
Et surtout activer la cloche
pour avoir un maximum de chance
de ne pas rater
les prochaines vidéos.
Ici, je vous en mets deux autres.
ça c'est une vidéo sur comment
devenir un génie du jour au lendemain.
Parce qu'on a trouvé une méthode,
apparemment qui fonctionne.
Il faut oser l'essayer.
Et là je vous mets une vidéo
sur la table de rappel
dont je vous parlais
pour la mémoire tout à l'heure.
Alors attention, c'est pas la même
qualité de vidéo qu'aujourd'hui,
parce que c'était
mes premières vidéos en 2016.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Je ne crois pas.
Prenez soin de vous,
à très bientôt.
Ciao !